good morning believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and I want
to see that great thing that you have
inside you explode out into the world
and have a big impact so to help you on
your journey today's message is take
risks over to you sundar Pichai you will
have many of many many opportunity
opportunities to reinvent yourself and
so you know so I think you know it's
worthwhile taking risks on trying to do
something you're really you know excited
by and if the first attempt you don't do
it you know you can try again and you
know things tend to work out in the long
run in Silicon Valley you know you know
parties and so many people start up at
companies you know starting a book
company and even having failed you can
wear it like a badge of honor right and
I think that's important you know
culturally you know risk is rewarded I
remember when I started working at
Google you know I if I went and you know
people who are discussing ideas to other
people who heard the ideas try to build
on those ideas they encouraged you so
it's a culture of optimism it's a
culture of risk-taking and I think
that's really important so so in case
you missed it in the video because I did
the first time he says you will have
many opportunities to reinvent yourself
and so you should go out and take the
risk and try it and I really love this
message and it's one that I haven't
heard too often so it's awesome to be
able to bring it to the channel it's so
easy to get lost in your current
situation it's so easy to get lost in
the present moment and to be stuck and
lonely look at the trees instead of be
able to take a step up and see the force
and and see a much bigger picture we get
lost in our current environment in our
current world and that prevents us from
making smart decisions that current
world will change so many times you will
have many opportunities to reinvent
yourself over the course of your life my
own story when I was in university I
thought I would want it to be a banker I
thought I want to get a job I was
working towards getting a job I want to
be a bank cuz it's what I want to do
everything was geared towards that life
change right sudden shift meet these
entrepreneurs join this company and now
it's all about the software company
and biotech and I know nothing about
science I know nothing about software
and I'm young and I doubt myself and
I've all these limiting beliefs that was
my world
I sold it and then what now I don't know
what I want to do I have become an
adventure capitalist and I'm all-in on
being a venture capitalist I'm learning
and understanding how to raise capital
I'm not super interested in it once I've
learned enough so I want to help
entrepreneurs how am I going to do that
I don't know I start by speaking I go to
the website now I'm all in on YouTube
YouTube won't be here forever right like
YouTube might last three years five
years ten years and then something else
comes along and that would be the next
shift and so I think it's easy to get
lost in the moment of what our current
short-term view of the world is and our
life is but when you have the extra
perspective to think of you know what
like I'm gonna have multiple careers
over my life like what happens right now
is not as important as you think it is
right it's not like you make one
decision here today and that's your life
for the rest of your life make the
decision if it doesn't work out it's
okay you will adjust you will change
once YouTube dies down like this is my
moment right now I have to go all-in on
that before that window closes but once
YouTube shifts it's okay
I will shift I will find the next thing
I will adjust right how the moment of
uncertainty and then find my next thing
and go hard on that and so the lesson
from this for me is when you find that
thing you got to do it because if your
goal is to be a youtuber as an example
if YouTube's not as big in five years or
ten years and something else is all the
rage like you missed your chance you
won't be a youtuber forever things will
change so when you have that idea when
you have that spark when you want to try
to do something instead of sitting on
the sidelines and watching somebody else
get rich off your idea and kicking
yourself as saying I should have done
that like I had it all lined up right I
had the idea I had the talent I had the
ability I just didn't believe in myself
I didn't take enough action instead of
just sitting on the sidelines being that
person do something and if it doesn't
work out it's okay because you'll have
multiple opportunities in the future to
continue to reinvent yourself this one
idea is not your forever idea so just
give it a shot and see if it works out
instead of living the rest of your life
wondering what if
so the question they today is I'm
curious I want to add a little bit of
pain to your life right now to help you
move forward in the positive direction
if you don't take massive action right
now this idea that you have inside your
head if you don't take massive action
right now to push through and make it
happen what's the biggest regret you're
gonna have in 10 20 30 years as you look
back on your life to know you could have
done more and you didn't
what's that regret let it fuel you
sharing the comments below and let's
make sure that that never happens I also
want to give a quick shout a to Carol
Rouen thank you so much for picking up a
copy of my book your one word I really
appreciate the support and I hope you
enjoyed the book so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of an espresso
[Music]
what's the biggest risk you've taken
that you feel is made of the biggest
risk I've taken that is I want to say
cookie I mean I was very nervous when I
received this cramped she wasn't the
most likable character and I've played
some pretty edgy characters but this one
was particularly a challenge because it
was primetime Network television and I
wasn't sure how people would receive her
I mean she beat her son with a broom
even though he deserved it um she called
once on a [ __ ] I mean it was it was
scary but I'm the type of artist that if
the role doesn't scare me I don't want
it because it's not gonna change me as a
person so I took a risk and that's what
you do as artists you jump in feet first
and you see where it goes and I knew
that we had something special
I don't just jump feet first for any
project I knew this was something
special I knew that what Fox was trying
to do with Lee Daniels and tani strong
we're trying to do and what I was trying
to do was shake up television it's too
safe you know life is not safe and I
think we did that with this show so I'm
so proud to be a part of this project
and I'm so proud that Fox believed in us
and took a chance because that's what
art is about isn't it taking chances
taking risks are you a risk taker
successful people are but not just
random app hazard like I'm driving drunk
without my seatbelt type of risk I'm
talking about calculated risks you weigh
the options you weigh the potential
outcome both good and bad and you make
the best decision possible but guys I'm
here to tell you that you are never
altima ting to be successful unless
you're willing to put yourself out there
having the ability or the willingness
the potentially fail is an absolute
benefit and sometimes these calculated
risks even though you thought about them
sometimes they just don't work out and
you know what successful people do
that's all right I learned something I
know what not to do next time and you
make another
calculated risk guys nothing great was
ever achieved because it was easy how
would you describe the place the band
was in going into the recordings for the
new album hunting party well I think
that we had comfortably gone way out of
where anyone who even was close to the
band would think we would go I think
it's it's been kind of fun to go
somewhere be creatively and then people
think they give you pegged and then you
go somewhere else and then they freak
out about it and then they kind of get
used to it and then they appreciate it
and then they think they have you pegged
and then you freaking go even crazier
but you've always done that you've
always wanted this thing where it's your
eyes it's it's scary because when we do
it we know we're doing it and we know
what that means the people who have
expectations then it's scary sometimes
to put a record out going we like it
which is the most important part that's
the most important thing for us we all
have to check off on everything which is
also is a very interesting process and
it's something that we've gotten better
at over time but I think it's really a
the reason why we laugh about it is
because we haven't gotten rid of the
process because it it is the best way to
include everyone in the band all the
time throughout the whole process to
make sure that when we put a record out
someone's not going what's that song
made it or I didn't you know why did
anybody tell me it is so it's it's one
of those things where you know we we've
learned how to take risks be confident
about it because we know that if we all
like it then we can stand behind it even
if everybody else says they don't which
would be shot the most important if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you up or
that would be like a little beacon
they believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details